thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with fabiano carolina for first of all
fabi how did you approach this game it
seems like your opening choice was just
wild
yeah well it was an interesting line
um it was a bit of a gamble
uh but i felt like it went well of
course i'm it's not a bad line for white
but it's very double-edged especially
this idea with rook to b1 rook to b to
tell us a little bit about that yeah
when i found this i was very attracted
to it because i like these sort of weird
ideas um
[Music]
it's basically the the point of the
position is that neither side can do
very much let's say after
after rook to b2
it explains his move h6 because if he
ever plays knight a5 then he has to
contend with e4
and if he ever plays e5 then d5 is very
good
so he he can't clearly improve his
position but also white can't
clearly
improve his position
so that's why i played h6 and i can also
play h3 but
i knew that this f4 idea was extremely
dangerous
and i decided to to go for it
although i
i don't know if what i did was correct
after
but yeah queen d7 i think was a really
good move because i was more considering
queen c3
rook d2
and queen a1
it looks a bit strange but he does
paralyze all my pieces
and then i thought maybe d5 is very
interesting and very dangerous for him
but this was also difficult to
understand because
my pieces are kind of hanging
you know i always have these ideas of
bishop b2 and some attack on the king
side but if he plays like bishop c4 here
i didn't see
um
how i was better so i was mostly
considering you should be two you just
simply take on d1 instead of one yeah
take on d1 i think he's even getting
better there i was going to tag on c4
rook d3 and some sort of complete
complete mess which i i was trying to
figure out while he was thinking and
then he surprised me with queen d7
at first i thought this can't be a very
good move
but
i thought a long time here i was mostly
considering uh e5 yeah
that was our focus as well yeah it's
very risky of course because i give away
all my squares but also very dangerous i
just
you know i'm going all all in for the
attack uh i think knight d5 is forced
rook c1 doesn't work out although it's
very tempting and here i was thinking
rook f2 is interesting
because i the immediate like trying to
attack doesn't work out if i play
let's say knight to h5 instead of rook
f2
then he has a very strong move i think
g6
uh
bishop d5 gh5 and
and i think this was the critical moment
the engine was proposing after g6 f5
yeah i considered it but i couldn't make
it work
um
sorry to interrupt cathy arena actually
won her game and bounced back a playoff
playoff of the day we'll have it later
today
okay and after f5 you said you were
doubtful i i didn't think it worked i
was calculating something here involving
gh5 but
i don't remember what it was
because we were looking at these
positions with bishop h6 and queen h5 we
thought it was good for you actually
strangely enough yeah
um i don't know it could could have been
i really thought this was critical but
after thinking for like 40 minutes
spending all my time on e5
i couldn't quite make it work um
and i thought the end game would be a
bit better for me but
once we got there
uh it looked like absolutely nothing and
then i started to outplay myself
he defended very very well
yeah absolutely but i think his his
moves are um
i mean he was very confident here his
moves are
uh are pretty much forced he has to take
this pawn
and like d6 instead of rookie a was the
most critical move but after d6 rook d4
knight f5 rook d2 visually it looks nice
you get your knight to f5 but the rook
on d2 is so strong that his knight comes
in my d-pawn is is more weakness than
the strength so he's he's not at all
worse here perhaps even knight b7 after
d6 yeah very often he has knight b7 just
grabbing
but after d6 knight b7 i thought rookie
8 and 94 was strong
um
yes kind of rookie king h794
i thought it was strong but maybe it's
also a draw fabi thank you for joining
us we've got some games that are about
to end and uh good luck tomorrow uh in
the match thank you for joining us
absolutely and of course the game that
has to have our attention is the one
between